I'm bill I serve chips he's a professor
or a lecturer or as I call him doctor
what and now we go everywhere
sure any faith where are we which way
sir
what's colic can I use the toilet any
time
and now I see everything there
[Music]
and it's not as bad as it sounds I'm the
doctor
I will save all your lives and when I do
you must spend the rest of the wondering
who I was
are you out of your mind yes completely
but that's not a recently he youtubers
is Charlie we got new Doctor Who series
10 trailer and the Christmas special so
let's break it down there's gonna be
some Sherlock coming up next week I'll
be doing videos for it so be sure to
subscribe to get that click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss any of
the videos so I'm going to start with
the trailer but there was this really
nice moment during the Christmas special
where the doctors kind of eulogizing
River Song
from last year's Christmas special so
we'll talk a little bit more about that
when I'm breaking down the episode but
he had this really nice speech about how
things end he was mostly talking about
River Song
dying and just being happy that she was
alive and enjoying the time that he had
with her but another really nice line
from the episode was this is really
getting meta so in a meta way the doctor
is eulogizing Peter Capaldi's time as
the doctor because the new season that
we're getting ready for later this year
is going to be his last Doctor Who
series 10 is supposed to at least at
this point is supposed to be Peter
Capaldi's last season is Doctor Who and
then after that they'll recast the role
there'll be a new doctor there'll be a
new showrunner because Steven Moffat is
leaving the series but we can talk about
that when it airs later in the year it's
not going to air for a long time but
pearl Mackie is going to be the new
companion as you saw in the trailer
in addition to providing comedic relief
she's also the explainer character like
what's a Dalek I don't understand
where's the bathroom in the TARDIS can I
use it this looks like a kitchen just
sort of subverting a lot of the classic
tropes of Doctor Who because if you're a
longtime watcher of Doctor Who and you
try to get your new friends to watch it
you have the exact same problem
there's just years and years of Doctor
Who continuity in history that you have
to make sense of in a really short
amount of time and even with people like
me that have YouTube channels dedicated
to following continuity and explaining
mythology and things like that it just
turns into a big headache so every once
in a while you need a new character like
pearl Matt
keys character whose name bill should
just introduce newer audiences to what
Doctor Who is and some of the broader
concepts so her name on the series is
going to be Bill Potts as you can see
she's a university student the doctor
plays something of the old professor
which I think Peter Capaldi is perfect
for like we've gone from really young
anachronistic versions of the doctor
like Matt Smith to slightly more
age-appropriate Peter Capaldi type
doctors they just do a better job of
reminding you that the doctor is over
2,000 years old
so that actually reminds me minor
correction Doctor Who is starting in
April but we don't know which weekend
but it's a Saturday show so it'll be one
of those Saturdays during April I don't
know if I'm going to be doing videos for
every single episode but leads to the
premiere probably do the finale in
between that we can figure that out
slightly related a lot of you are also
asking about Sherlock yes I am going to
be doing Sherlock next week that starts
January 1st the first episode so I'll
remind everyone when I post my next
Sherlock video but the Christmas special
the return of doctor Mysterio so we
learned that doctor Mysterio is not
Justin Chatwin who sort of playing the
super hero of the episode it's actually
the doctor who he as a child dubs doctor
Mysterio so when the episode says the
return of doctor Mysterio it's the
return of Doctor Who and I think that
they chose that title for meta reasons
because in the context of the story the
doctors been gone for 24 years because
he's been spending all that time with
River Song since this moment in the last
Christmas special where she's like it's
a shame that we only have this last
night together like they have one night
in there on this foreign planet and then
she's like how long do Knights last on
this planet and he's like oh about 24
years so she just laughs because it's
like okay they have a lot of time left
together but in the real world he's been
gone for these past 24 years so this
young boy has grown up he still has
these superpowers but don't worry you
know you can enjoy your new life with
your girlfriend here and the baby
because the doctor is back I'll take
care of everything
doctor Mysterio has returned for those
of you asking about the timeline though
this is the way it goes so you have that
moment with River Song the series 9
Christmas finale the husbands of River
Song she goes on after that to the
silence in the library that two-part
episode
dies but while she's doing that going
off to the library to have that final
adventure with the David Tennant doctor
the 12th doctor Capaldi is coming back
to modern day so in the context of
Doctor Who this episode is happening
right after silence in the library like
right after River dies but the episode
itself was more of a play on the recent
trend of superhero comic book movies so
the doctor made fun of spider-man there
was a bunch of Marvel all over the
wallpaper in his bedroom he was reading
a Golden Age Superman comic so a lot of
Doctor Who poking fun at superheroes so
like when they were doing the Clark Kent
Superman stuff in the episode it was
really over-the-top like it was meant to
be very kitschy it almost played a lot
like the energy of the 90s Dean Cain
Superman series just really on the nose
with the humor it almost didn't feel
like a Doctor Who episode because there
was so much American stuff going on
inside of it like this was taking place
in New York City instead of in London
where it usually would take place but
there was a whole bunch of wordplay in
like the first 15 minutes of the episode
they dropped a ton of Easter eggs like
oh I always get a cold during Christmas
and the doctor says yeah I usually get
colds too or invasions talking about the
Christmas invasion the very first
episode that David Tennant debuted in
then he says my name is the doctor any
assam witch doctor are you we have lots
of doctors and he says I'm the original
one everybody else is copying me so he's
making fun of Doctor Strange they're
making fun of all the other previous 12
doctors like there are a lot of doctors
in Doctor Who but in the world of
superheroes there's also lots of doctor
superheroes as well so the doctor is
constructing something to fix all of the
time aberrations that have been
happening in New York City New York City
itself has been the setting for many
Doctor Who episodes there was the Angels
Take Manhattan but I think more
pointedly there was Daleks in Manhattan
and then the sequel to that evolution of
the Daleks which were actually David
Tennant episodes but New York City
itself shows up during many more Doctor
Who adventures going all the way back to
classic Doctor Who
so the doctor is basically saying a lot
of crazy has been happening in New
York especially lately I'm trying to fix
it but then Grant eats the jewel it
draws upon the power to give him
whatever he
wants to do so he becomes a superhero
because he is obsessed with superheroes
like most kids are the invasion of the
body snatchers aliens that are trying to
take over in the episode are actually
new they haven't been featured on Doctor
Who before but it's a very invasion of
the body snatchers story where they're
just trying to replace everyone with
aliens one of the unit soldiers was
replaced at the very end of the episode
so they might follow up on that during
series 10 but there is now another alien
working inside unit in disguise little
more nefarious than Osgood but this
isn't the first time an alien has
infiltrated unit they had the big Zygon
invasion episode there was the question
of which Osgood remained after series 8
is this Zygon Osgood is this original
human Osgood so we'll see what happens
with unit during series 10 the whole
brains in jars reminded me of Futurama
just like heads sitting in jars on
shelves together as well as the headless
monks but speaking of headless nardole
comes back from the previous Christmas
special that was the River Song story
that they kept referencing at the end of
this episode so he's a human cyborg
that's why the doctor said I put you
back together you have to do what I say
so he's helping the doctor out probably
till he picks up bill here at University
she becomes the new companion but let me
know in the comments what are you guys
excited for in series 10 who do you want
to come back it sounds like they're
trying to reintroduce a lot of classic
things through the bill character and
explain it for new audiences like look
at all this awesome stuff we have so I
would expect a lot of deep cuts along
with a bunch of new stuff mixed in just
showing off the whole breadth of Doctor
Who history in a way that new people can
understand so I will say the Christmas
episode probably not my favorite I like
the river song Christmas episode last
year a little bit better but I tend to
like the more serious Doctor Who stories
with a little bit of comedy in them more
than the light-hearted stories like this
one with a little bit of serious stuff
in them like they really only got
serious at the very end when the doctors
basically saying that things and we
should be happy for the time that we
have with them basically like I said
eulogizing River Song saying that she's
dead now and also saying that Peter
Capaldi is going to be leaving Doctor
Who soon it's kind of sad but everything
ends they make way for new exciting
things to be
again just letting you know it's going
to be sad that Capaldi isn't around
anymore but we'll have somebody new
it'll be really exciting so I wouldn't
expect them to announce that till
towards the end of Doctor Who series 10
but they probably know who the next
doctor is already so get hyped we're
still on justice league trailer watch
there's going to be couple other big
trailers dropping in the next couple of
days there's still some marble DC stuff
I'll be doing and some Sherlock that
I'll be posting next week so look out
for that what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to rewatch the
alien covenant video and you can click
here for my breakdown to the latest
Justice League teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tonight
hmm